مرة أخرى ، تحذير واشنطن من
عملية العلم الكامل ، هل قدموا أي
دليل على ذلك لك ،
أه
هو تصور
بالنسبة لي ، أنا في الأساس أحاول
إجراء فهمي
للتأثيرات كما ذكرت من قبل في هذه اللحظة
في هذه اللحظة  في مثل هذا اليوم في هذا التاريخ
لم يقم الروسي
بصياغة القوات الضاربة
أه
هذا كل شيء
ولكن أه الخطر أو التهديدات
لا يزال لدينا هذا منذ 2014
ثم احتلوا شبه جزيرة القرم ثم قاموا
بالاعتداء على أوكرانيا في
الدون لذا فالمخاطر والتهديدات لدينا
لا
يزال بإمكانهم
تنسيق هذا التشكيل اللافت ، لكنهم
يحتاجون إلى الوقت لذلك وسيروا ما
إذا كانوا سيبدأون هذا التشكيل ،
لذا أعني
أن أعداد القوات المسلحة
للروس إلى جانب حدودنا في هذه
اللحظة معقولة جدًا.
قبل عيد الفصح في الربيع الماضي ،
هذا هو الاختلاف ، لذلك لدينا
نفس الحقائق
ولكن الفرق في الإدراك أو
التقدير المختلف ، فإن الاختلاف
يتعلق بمسألة النية لك  لا
أصدق أنهم يعتزمون الغزو ، آمل
ألا يتخذوا قراراتهم في الكرملين بعد